Yeah.
And now,
you know,
with bill,
she's 16 and now we have motion one oh three,
the nts homophobia bill and then the whole child and family services act has
been now changed to a bill 89.
And uh,
basically if your child,
if Jimmy comes home and identifies as a girl,
um,
and do you kind of,
you know,
talk them out of it or saying it in a no.
Uh,
you could have cs at your doorstep.
Hold off on the puberty delay,
uh,
hormones there,
Kiddo.
You might change your mind.
Yeah.
You could keep your breasts for a while and chased you decide that you're wrong.
I consider this child abuse as a form of child protection worker for eight
years.
To me this is a flat out child abuse that's being sanctioned by the state.
And uh,
what I'm really surprised about is that more and more parents aren't speaking
out about this.
They dropped their litter with a movement.
There are terrified.
Like the teachers are terrified.
Serena,
there's going to be lawsuits Galore in 15 years though,
that's for sure.
These kids who from whom consent is being derived,
despite the fact that there have no age to provide consent,
are going to be a vicious legal protagonists when they go after the physicians
and,
and other authorities who've made these reprehensible decisions.
I wanted to talk to you briefly vote the law society and about what's happening
recently,
the doctors and the law society.
Uh,
and basically the issues that you were talking with in predicting.
Now we see them come true.
Okay.
So,
uh,
when the loss,
see I think that the Law Society of Ontario will succeed in its pushed to make a
statement of principles reflecting social justice ideology mandatory.
I think they're going to win that.
Um,
I think there will be lawyers who will refuse to write it,
that will take them to court and then it'll be dragged out for a long time.
But,
um,
as soon as the law society capitulates are soon as the lawyers capitulate,
which they show virtually every sign of doing that,
every professional organization and counted is going to follow suit.
I don't know if you saw the agenda episode where Steve Pakan had a whole panel
of lawyers on it.
They were talking about this.
No,
I didn't see it.
It just,
uh,
it was actually quite recent.
I'd say maybe the last two,
three weeks,
but you should look it up and you're right.
They have capitulated.
Like,
it was pretty obvious to me that this is where we're headed right.